Speaker 1: why don't we go next to Gabe from
Louisiana? Gabe, welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. Hey, can you hear
me? Yes. Hey. So I have a question about the
Republican response to the 2022 midterms. Okay.
So I was. Very much scared that many Republicans
would refuse to concede. However, based on what
I've seen, it seems to mainly just be Kerry
Lake, unless there's someone I'm not aware of.
Speaker 1: No, it's basically. You have like you.
Speaker 3: Yeah. So do you have any idea why they
may have backed off from that? Do
you think it might be because they
see that, you know, the Trump candidates
didn't do well, so they're trying to distance
themselves or what do you think? It's two.
Speaker 1: Things. I think it's number one,
they saw the trend and a lot of these people
lost. And the idea that it was all fraud, even if
some Republican voters would buy it, seems like
a very hard case to make because a lot of these
were individual state cases. That's number one.
Secondly, I think it's that it's now been two
years of Trump and people around Trump trying to
overturn the results. And it hasn't worked. And if
Trump wasn't able to do it, I can't imagine they
think they will be able to succeed. So I think
it's some of them recognize the futility of it.
Speaker 3: Okay. Awesome. That very much answers
my question. Thank you so much for your insight,
David. I really appreciate it. All right.
Speaker 1: Gabe from Louisiana,
great to hear from you